who's been messing up everything it's
been agatha
all along who's been pulling every evil
string
it's been agatha all along while agatha
harkness's not so surprised reveal on
one division finally confirmed the
long-standing theory
about the true identity of agnes the
nosy neighbor it also left a burning
question
what are the origins and limits of
harkness's power let's look at
everything we know so far about
agatha hagnes both in the show and her
comic book appearances
to try and come up with an answer who
are you who are you
in marvel comics proper agatha harkness
is an old woman
an old old woman she's got memories
stretching back 500 years before
atlantis sank
which marvels in universe historians
place around 10
500 bc basically harkness predates every
known human civilization
and she's outlasted all of them you know
what they say
with age comes wisdom and since wisdom
is power for the magically inclined
essentially harkness is powerful because
of her age
but that's only part of the equation she
draws from three sources of magical
power
her own personal well of energy ambient
magic that pervades the marvel universe
and extra-dimensional energy that exists
in entities and objects
housed in tangential dimensions these
three sources give harkness a near
limitless source of power
but we're still not done in the marvel
universe witches and warlocks rely on
the goddess of witchcraft
even the sorceress supreme is powerless
without her at one point in marvel canon
the goddess was for lack of a better
term killed by another supreme deity
chaos when wonder maximoff and the ghost
of her mother and harkness resurrected
the goddess of witchcraft
that act also resurrected harkness
herself this could imply some special
link between her
and the goddess that goes far beyond
what normal spellcasters experience
which could explain her power but
there's an important point to consider
about the marvel comics version of
agatha harkness
and the source material she's not
inherently evil she's not even really a
villain
and i killed sparky too
[Laughter]
stay with us here it's true that
witchcraft is traditionally associated
with darkness those who deal in the
macabre are typically considered evil
it's why the salem witch trials were a
real thing but marvel comics makes it
clear harkness is anything but a baddie
as stephanie williams wrote in a rundown
of agatha hagnus for marvel
agatha harkness may be a lot of things
but inherently evil is not one of them
sure she does things that may make you
raise an eyebrow or at first glance
project villainous energy
but upon taking an in-depth look it's
not that black and white
not convinced consider this in her very
first appearance in marvel comics
reed and susan richards of the fantastic
four hired agatha harkness as a nanny
in 1970s fantastic four number 94
they enlisted her to watch over their
newborn son franklin richards
and she was more than up to the task of
defending the powerful infant from the
frightful four
on the other hand harkness did also kind
of kidnap franklin a few years later
in fantastic four number 185 but hey
long story short it was for a really
good reason of course he has seen on tv
version of agatha harkness
has definitely been cast in a villainous
light so far
but we wouldn't be surprised if she ends
up going the way of loki
and becoming a fan favorite anti-hero
after this first
let's say awkward encounter gets all
cleared up
most of agatha hagnes's comic history is
unaccounted for
there's a huge gap between 10 500 bc
and the 1600s after all but it's implied
that she's always been powerful
conversely the marvel cinematic
universe's harkness had to struggle a
bit for her powers
which came at a huge cost during a
flashback scene
one division reveals that the mcu
harkness wasn't in charge of the salem
coven
her mother held that position but even
being the boss witch's daughter didn't
immunize harkness from being charged
with essentially stealing knowledge
beyond her age and station and
practicing the darkest of magic
these crimes were punishable by death
unfortunately whatever harkness did
granted her powers she couldn't quite
control
including the ability to seemingly
reflect spells back at her executioners
with fatal results
this darkest of magic is clearly the
source of harkness's strength in one
division but as the series gears up for
its big finale
the origin of her magic in the mcu
remains a mystery
wow that's something special baby
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite
movies and tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one